voilà bonjour alors est ce que un
confinement est imminent notamment en
ile de france tout le monde se pose la
question alors écoutez c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué que ça et même si
tout porte à penser qu'il y aurait est
un confinement
les avis des ministres et du président
diffèrent emmanuel macron or et émis des
réserves quant au confinement
le week end à poissy l'expliquent
c'était compliqué de confiner en
ile-de-france il souhaitait néanmoins
une mesure de freinage mieux adapté à la
vie francilienne et selon le maire de
poissy karl olive les échanges qu'ils
ont eus
elle n'allait pas dans le sens du
confinement pour le moment on ne sait
pas encore grand chose néanmoins le
président a indiqué qu'il fallait quand
même agi en monaco faut-il y voir
voyez vous l'avez dit magali le
président a répété il l'a répété il va
falloir prendre des mesures en
ile-de-france et dans les hautes france
des réponses plus fine en tout cas ce
sont ces termes c'est ce qu'a confirmé
également y lire gabriel attaque
le porte-parole du gouvernement écoutez
le
la tendance de ces dernières semaines ne
s'est pas démenti et si le confinement
le week end a permis de freiner
l'épidémie notamment dans les
alpes-maritimes
l'épidémie continue à progresser dans
certaines régions et à progresser
fortement dans certaines régions je
pense notamment à l'ile-de-france et à
la région au de france 2 cela nous
tirons d'ores et déjà deux enseignements
d'abord la stratégie localiser reste la
bonne stratégie elle permet de limiter
de manière précise et proportionnée
l'expansion du virus
ensuite le deuxième constat le deuxième
enseignement c'est que nous devons
prendre dans les territoires les plus
touchés des mesures supplémentaires le
président de la république sait qu'il
joue gros et il sait que chaque décision
lourde de conséquences sur le moral des
français d'ailleurs un sondage bva du
mois de février révèle que sa cote de
popularité est en hausse une hausse qui
serait due notamment à la stratégie
sanitaire et à la décision de l'exécutif
de ne par confiner pour le moment
emmanuel mâcon veut donc rester sur
cette dynamique
n oubliez pas les présidentielles sont
en sont dans un an et il sait que chaque
décision compte pour regagner la
confiance des français et notamment des
jeunes le président de la république
semble vouloir avancer à tâtons alors
mona si les avis divergent
qu est ce qu on sait qu est ce qui a
fuité de l'ambiance lors du conseil de
défense sanitaire
et bien selon nos confrères du point le
conseil de défense sanitaire a été
décrit comme très froid notamment
marquée aussi par l'agacement du
président de la république à l'encontre
d'olivier veyrat le ministre de la santé
qui lui plaidé pour un confinement toute
la semaine ou même de tout le pays deux
mesures qui ont été rejetées par le
président de la république est également
par bruno le maire ou encore gérald
darmanin
et puis vous voyez cette situation elle
est un petit peu compliqué les avis sont
différents et pour l'instant personne ne
sait s'il y aura un confinement ou pas
il faudra attendre la traditionnelle
conférence de presse du jeudi d'olivier
veyrat et est de jean castex mais selon
elle des élus locaux emmanuel macron a
également indiqué qu'il voulait se
projeter en mai pour une potentielle
réouverture des musées et des
restaurants mais souvenez-vous gabriel
atta le porte parole du gouvernement
avait indiqué qu on retrouverait
peut-être une vie un peu plus normale à
la mi avril
pour l'instant on est loin du compte et
souvenez-vous on l'a bien vu et bien
l'épidémie nous a réservé bien des
surprises
merci mona amoud et l'or en direct
devant le ministère de la santé à paris
une conférence de fraises qui sera
débriefer bien évidemment sur rt france
notamment à 20h dans l'info avec
stéphanie 2 me